[Musique]
et très dur il a par contre merci pour
sa part insisté
mais
qu'est ce qu'il manque c'est un peu
bouché mais ça va frérot en fait je
venais de voir pour un truc spécial
capté que c'est spécial en fait
j'aimerais bien ce qu'ils ont fait ce
sont des formations chez sur une chute
et aux dons qu'on a je vois
quelqu'un va montrer des vidéos d'aidé
ou de même un article un truc que je
peux voir que j'ai ramené j'ai pas de
vidéo mais j'ai une échographie fier de
mon fils
mais c'est sa séquence et quand ces
images là nul profite mais non non non
c'est la photo la plus récente que j'ai
trouvé de l'huile à
la maintenant il est comme ça bah ouais
je sais c'est posé le chien je suis pas
directeur de la garderie j'essaie si on
peut
participer acquis moi je suis je suis
recruteur de marseille je fais tu
pour dire ton fils il peut pas jouer là
ils marchent ma boîte
là il est dans le monde de la mode oui
mais comment on fait pour une ferme et
est
de sprint de 40 m par exemple d'acheter
clic et mbappé oui il est camerounais
algérien d'accord lui moi je suis
vraiment fort mais le sénégalais
sinon
bah non il jouera pas pour l'équipe de
france j'ai appris qu'il du brésil où tu
y as je crois que tu fous quoi bondir
les coûts devront pas passé par quatre
chemins je vais dire la vérité moi ce
que je pense maintenant tu me donnes 3
millions d'euros le bébé est appartient
ok ok ok ok ok ok 10000 euros dix mille
euros il est à toi dix mille balles
c'est tout et chainel ma carte il y
mettait à vis dans mon cabas pour toi
t'as pas mis tous tes ennemis il est
même les gens qui t'aiment pas tout tous
et tous pour toi et le prochain bébé at
war gratuit race on n'en parle plus de
dix mille balles
ouais bon marché conclut la carte
capable merci pour votre soutien
attendons par contre l'un des mythes aux
randonneurs ouais l'attaqué sera là
voilà voilà ça c'est beaucoup du brief
[Musique]